m maison du dragon
de mon sang
vient le prince qui a été promis
et son sera le chant
de glace et de feu
[Musique]
fardeau de cette connaissance
est plus grand que le trône
il est plus grand que toi
[Musique]
le roi a choisi  vanira
le royaume n'acceptera pas ses
hommes préféreraient mettre le royaume au
flambeau
et voir une femme monter sur le trône de fer
je serai la reine des sept royaumes
faite comme vous le souhaitez
quand j'aurai froid dans ma tombe
[Musique] les
rêves ne l'ont pas fait  faites de nous des rois
dragons
mais les gens se souviennent de
l'ancienne force de la maison targaryen
aucun roi n'a jamais vécu qui n'a pas
dû perdre la vie de quelques-uns pour protéger
les nombreux
vous n'êtes pas conquérant vous êtes un fléau
nos maisons sont liées par un  cause commune
peut-être mais il y aura du sang
[Musique]
toi